the first thing I'm going to say is I'll
put good money on the suggestion because
I didn't tell you to do it but I put
good money dad got a lot of you did not
start the question like this you just
started saying hey equals now I kind of
alluded to the fact there in this
question a could be a variety of
different things right because a always
means area but there are lots of areas
involved there's the area we want which
is the basis right this circle there's
the area the surface area of the entire
cone and then there's the area of just
the curved part right so I think it's
important to actually say that cuz
you're about to say da or blah blah blah
so therefore you you want to actually
say what a is then later on when you've
got different kinds of areas of you're
comparing that's gonna be vitally
important tell me what you're actually
what you I did skip over the stamp on it
now once I've said this I know what the
area of a circle is but I'm not going to
work with this equation I could there's
nothing wrong with luck or something
incorrect about it but it's just not the
most direct path I'm after how a is not
changing with a switch radius but how a
is changing with respect to height okay
so one of the tricky things about
related rates questions is that you've
got all these variables flying around
and you kind of have to sift through the
Melilla okay now as you say because of
this particular case is like it's a very
nice example because you've got this
nice isosceles triangle here I can
actually just substitute R for H and
then I can proceed but if I had given
you this question where it was both the
case and you really encounter questions
where that's not the case you're likely
gonna have to use some combination of
offline Pythagoras
yeah or if you were given the angles and
they went like 45 degrees you'd have to
use treatment
okay so are you ready for me proceed
Rebecca where I'm heading
I would leave for dl/dt now I don't even
eat E and then I nerd hey so how am I
going to connect all of these pieces
together suggestion yep okay so yes the
LD T equals D a on th I can't very good
so let's have a look at this you can see
part a leads me to path B right because
I could come back all the way to volume
but volume and this surface area are not
connected in neat ways right they are
connected right if if volume and high
are connected an area are heightening
did that beads more you can hide a also
connected but the way they're connected
is a bit of a mess why not just use this
to HIV T that I already have it's a much
more direct link between these two okay
so therefore here I'm going to say D a
on D H which of course is 2 pi so now I
can take this and I've got all the
pieces of in Eastern island right this
is 2 pi H times what to be second
okay and I can see all this lovely
canceling that happens cancel cancel
cancel yep so I'm getting six over H
that's all that's left
so you can see it related to H questions
again number one you've got to navigate
the fact that so many variables are in
play and believe it or not you'll
encounter questions for intuitive quite
a few more variables and this is
something we'll cruise secondly you'll
notice the differentiation is not hard
right like you're often dealing with
geometry and the formulas are really
easy actually to differentiate like you
could do the bit you're sleep
the hard part is you have to pick what
you have to differentiate and then
combined it with the right ways to get
what you want yeah so when do is I
interested in when H is goes to da over
DT his six on two which is three that's
just a number so now I'm going to
conclude therefore area is changing at
and what are my units okay
now even this question it's not relevant
later on it will be I will just point
out that just like a just like a
gradient of a line can be negative a
rate of change for a quantity could also
be negative if this was say negative
three what would that mean about the
area as time progresses that means it's
getting smaller that's one of the small
so I'm against a negative three he and
it's not only the case like if the
question was you know water's being
taken out of the bottom of the barrel
whatever I wouldn't say it area you know
the area of that water is changing at
negative three meters squared per minute
I'm using natural language so instead
I'd say something like the area is
decreasing right so really I should is
that increasing here but that right
whether it's getting bigger or smaller
it's baked into the sign of the
derivative yeah so we've got all of this
language we redevelop and now in breathe
to something that's cooking okay are
there any questions on these parts of
the exam yes so you're thinking of you
think you're writing this is that what
you're thinking of writing
okay so let's pause for a second um I
have already kind of put my cards on the
table as to what I think is the clearest
way to write it I probably would not
write a - whatever
because which F are you talking about
like I mean like I suppose you could
define an F but there are so many things
in this whole question that could
legitimately because F I think that's a
bit misleading
this is a little bit better because I
are now I'm looking at area but then
it's like area with respect to what like
I know I've written area with respect to
time that's the only a derivative that I
have but I could have written I shall
start taking it back I have this student
I have two derivatives in a Ruth
respected three different variables so I
go to Lena wait for this and I'm just
gonna say tell me what you'll do for me